have you gotten to meet some like rap
icons and stuff like that damn that's
crazy bro yeah I met Tupac Mama bro
before she passed it was crazy
yeah that [__] was crazy and [__] and
then like I met Park Mama right so they
got the Grammy
um
they was doing something it was Grammy
weekend and they had a a Tupac
um
I think it was like a museum some with
the Grammys though and uh you feel me
like they wanted me to come speak you
feel me on the behalf of the
the the uh new generation at the time it
was like 2015. Wow and they wanted me to
come speak on them behalf of the new
generations like Tupac impact
on us you you know the [__] who
grew up like
grew up listening a pop
when he passed I said you know right
um so
you know I'm saying I go I speak on on
like you send me the news generation and
just you know I'm saying how I felt and
and pop impact you know what I'm saying
and then uh you're all upset like I said
some [__] in his mama uh but she came to
me [__] and was like crying and [__] she
was like I love what you said about my
son
I'm like yeah yeah it's a show and then
she just looking at me and she crying
she like they really killed my baby they
really killed my baby I'm like God damn
bro that's it [__] me up cause like
I thought POC was alive
I thought pot was alive bro I hope but
my whole life bro I thought Park was
alive but that day that day
I'm like nah bro he gone dog his mama
was crying in my face no he's gone
but that [__] [__] me up bro
yeah it was sad as [__] bro damn what'd
you do do you like hold her or something
what was she was she really broken up
yeah no he was holding hands and [__]
like this you know what I'm saying but
no but it really hurts her a lot yeah
yeah I mean I can't of course it does
because it's your child but still
for her to say that right in front of
you man that's powerful yeah I got a
picture I got a picture with her
beautiful we was talking and [__] oh if
y'all on Google y'all Google with y'all
on yeah I think you can find it probably
maybe YG and uh Miss Shakur
oh fine you I I'm funny
it's dope
I'm like damn I'm at Park Mama wow and
had her crying
off the real shoot
you think I just said some real [__] oh
that's cool bro here go right there
wow
that's legendary man yeah so when you
say rap you know what I'm saying I find
secure she like an icon you know I'm
saying rapper but she Pock Mama [__] you
feel me being hurt I was big I was one
of the biggest little situations hope
you enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you a one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one